the late justice ginsburg will make
history one last time this week
when the nation honors her in washington
jan crawford is outside the supreme
court where that formal farewell begins
tomorrow morning
jan what events are going to be held
i've heard there's a lot of really
important things going on for her
yes and it's all going to start tomorrow
i mean right now
you'd never believe it it's just almost
strange here because it's just so quiet
like
this calm before the storm of a
confirmation battle that we all
know is coming but tomorrow and then
thursday the court will begin to
memorialize her and then members of the
public
can come and pay their respects justice
ginsburg is going to lie in repose
tomorrow and thursday at the top of the
steps here at the supreme court after a
private
service inside the courtroom for her
family
close friends the justices and their
spouses her casket
is going to arrive here at the court
just before 9 30 in the morning and
taken
into the building by supreme court price
off
police officers they'll be greeted by
some of her former law clerks who will
be serving as
honorary pallbearers and then she'll
line repose
underneath the portico at the top of
those steps until 10 o'clock on thursday
night
on friday justice ginsburg is going to
lie in state
at the u.s capitol which for a woman who
was
so often the first is also going to be a
first like
anthony said earlier she's going to be
the first woman
to the lion state inside the national
statuary
hall there will be a private internment
service
next week at arlington memorial cemetery
where she will be buried
next to her beloved husband of 56 years
marty gail oh boy i've heard so much
about the marriage that she had jan you
just said that she's the first woman to
ever lie in state at the capitol let's
just think about that for a second
number one sorry that it's taken so long
but if you have to be a first it's so
fitting that it would be she
you covered her for many years what what
does this moment mean when you think
about her legacy
you know it's hard to even kind of put
it into words gail because i think that
you know i've never covered anything
like it in the 26 years
that i've covered the court i think we
have to look back years when you see
you know a battle to replace a
pioneering trailblazing figure who
you know led a life committed to
equality for all this is really a unique
moment
i think in our nation's history not only
for her legacy and what she meant to the
country
but for what the country is now about to
go through with the battle over her
successor
all right jan we're all watching more to
come thank you very much